[Music]
on this sunday night the ottawa
occupation is over
police secure parliament hill but the
downtown remains in lockdown this is not
the normal state of our city the
measures police are taking to prevent
protesters from returning
more military maneuvers near ukraine
spark a last-ditch effort at diplomatic
talks could be really the biggest war in
europe since 1945 plus kovid and the
queen well wishes for her majesty after
the 95 year old tests positive for the
virus and olympic look back the highs
and lows of the beijing winter games
[Music]
national
reporting tonight jeff semple
[Music]
for the first time in more than three
weeks the streets of downtown ottawa are
largely quiet and calm now the police
operation isn't over yet officers remain
in the area around parliament hill
clearing out the last of the protesters
and working to ensure they can't return
police are also removing vehicles and
debris left behind by the demonstrators
good evening and thank you for joining
us the nation's capital looks very
different than it did just 24 hours ago
but the city is not back to normal just
yet heavy security measures remain in
place in the downtown core and there's
no word on exactly when those might be
lifted our david aiken has been covering
the protests since the start and he
joins us with the latest from ottawa
david
well jeff the chief objective of police
on this sunday is to hold the ground
that they won on saturday and so as a
result throughout the parliamentary
precinct blocks and blocks you've seen
this installed
two meter high strong fencing to keep
people out and beyond that stretching
for further blocks throughout the
downtown core look at this
one police checkpoint after another
there's dozens of them on wellington
street the road running by all the
parliament buildings relative peace and
calm free of the trucks protests and
encampments of the last few weeks on
sunday police continued to clear other
streets of abandoned vehicles and pushed
pockets of other protesters further away
from the core and made more arrests
still it's not clear when the trudeau
government will lift or suspend the
federal emergencies act we will
eliminate them as quickly as we are able
and and the the response is only what
was necessary in order to to protect
canadian interests bill blair did
clarify one aspect of the most
controversial powers in that act the
freezing of bank accounts for those
aiding the occupying protesters those
who donated 25 dollars here 50 dollars
there need not worry he says their
accounts will not be frozen we're not
concerned about you know who made a
donation to what that's that's that's
not a matter for the police it's not a
concern to us meanwhile ontario's
special investigations unit has assigned
eight people to look into some of
saturday's police activity including the
discharge by police of a weapon that
fires plastic projectiles into a crowd
of protesters that police said were
getting violent and another allegation
that a woman suffered a serious injury
after being struck by a mounted police
officer police say that last allegation
is an example of the misinformation
deliberately spread by the protesters
there was two members of the protesters
who did collide with the horses they
fell down they immediately got back up
and started to again engage in in their
protest and demonstration activity
ottawa police also updated some stats
from saturday's operation and here they
are more than 50 vehicles towed and
seized nearly 200 people arrested and of
those
107 are facing criminal charges jeff
david aiken in ottawa thanks david
many residents of ottawa are breathing a
sigh of relief tonight after three weeks
of complaints about harassment noise and
unease during the demonstration shaun
o'shea joins us from inside the security
zone so sean you were out speaking with
residents today what did they have to
say jeff we set out to
do east of here to the byward market
area that's an area that's very popular
with both tourists and with locals alike
and many businesses most businesses in
that area were closed on friday and
saturday because of the police action
and the
biggest shopping mall or one of the
biggest shopping malls in canada the
rito center remains closed after three
weeks
now some residents did venture out today
many for the first time in a while
they told us they were relieved that the
protesters and those trucks have finally
gone here's what some of them had to say
to us earlier
it's just wonderful to walk out and not
have to worry about being
actually harassed or harmed it's great
it feels great that
like my friend was saying that things
are getting back to normal and while
yeah there's a heavy police presence now
at least
at least it's the police and not a bunch
of random people from outside of our
city coming in and uh shutting
everything down and i think some of
these businesses probably are really
hurting for patrons so i thought okay
let's walk around let's see what's
what's going on and see if we can you
know get a coffee somewhere or walk
around and just see what's open now not
everything is back to normal those are
some of the prisoner transport vehicles
just down here from parliament hill
the war memorial there there were some
officers taking photos there this area
is still all sealed off so things are
definitely not back to normal as people
in ottawa know normal but those
protesters who had been here for three
weeks they have gone the honking is gone
the diesel has gone and at some point at
some point this area will be restored to
what people in ottawa know as normal we
just do not know when that will happen
as yet jeff shanoshay in a very quiet
nation's capital thanks sean
moving now to another police
investigation in northern bc rcmp
officers are hunting for suspects after
a brazen attack on the work site of a
natural gas pipeline coastal gas link
says its facility and nine workers were
attacked early thursday morning police
say the damage to the site including
buildings and equipment is estimated
around 6 million dollars emadagahi joins
us now from near the site with an update
ahmad
since thursday morning rcmp
investigators from across the province
of bc have been gathering in the
northern communities of houston and
smithers to investigate what they are
calling a criminal act and now we can
see some of the evidence that they are
working with
the work site is remote more than 60
kilometers of service road separate this
natural gas pipeline construction zone
from houston in bc's bulkeley valley
operations here have stopped as police
are on site investigating there's a
clear escalation of violence this was in
the middle of the night this is a
coordinated effort by multiple people
the rcmp and coastal gas link the
pipeline company say the alleged attack
happened shortly after midnight on
thursday it's claimed around 20 people
dressed in camouflage and masks carrying
power tools and an axe confronted nine
overnight workers at the site
those workers fled for their own safety
and according to the pipeline company
the attacker stormed onto the site
hijacking heavy equipment to cause what
police tell us is an estimated six
million dollars in damage to machinery
and infrastructure rcmp also say the
alleged attackers impeded the responding
officers who were traveling the only
road to the site
by throwing smoke canisters at them
burning logs were placed on the roadway
and booby traps were set up as well at
one point a large school bus had been
parked blocking the road
to the site one officer was injured in
the response but no arrests could be
made
how did the attackers get away if there
was just one road to come in
so there's from my understanding there
are several trail systems that are
in off of the side roads and offshoots
it was dark
from blockades to injunctions and
arrests the project has been through a
myriad of pipeline disputes but this
weekend rcmp told us there's no evidence
yet connecting this incident to previous
protest movements this is despite what
appears to be clear anti-pipeline
graffiti on one of the damaged trailers
the rcmp is mentioned is investigating
this as a criminal act and not a breach
of injunction which they have been
previously
enforcing and we're also told by police
officers and investigators that they
have obtained video surveillance from
the site that may be released if it
helps further their investigation jeff
matagahi near houston bc thanks
canada's foreign minister is cancelling
plans to travel to germany for a
security summit and instead returning to
canada amid rising tensions over ukraine
belarus now says russian forces will
remain stationed in that country
indefinitely the move deepening concerns
that russia is planning to attack
ukraine and forcing yet another round of
high-level diplomacy reggie jacini has
the latest from washington
a menacing military might surrounding
ukraine is only growing more threatening
as the bella russian defense ministry
performs an about face announcing
russian military drills will be extended
we believe that putin has made his
decision
period belarus claims it to be a
response to ukrainian aggression but
western leaders are rife with concern
the plan that we're seeing
is for something that could be really
the biggest war in europe since 1945.
after weeks of shuttle diplomacy failed
to make any breakthroughs
there's a renewed sense of urgency that
could see the white house and kremlin
speaking again my job as a diplomat is
to leave absolutely no stone in turn to
see if we can prevent a war there are
fears a pretext for invasion is already
being drafted the u.s embassy in russia
issuing an alert citing the potential
for attacks in major centers and near
the ukraine border while russian-backed
rebels are alleged to be opening fire in
breakaway regions in the east blaming
ukraine the west has threatened
wide-ranging consequences but only in a
reactive manner these are some of the
greatest sanctions if not the the
strongest that we've ever issued with
russia's president holding his cards
against his chest the white house
national security council met on sunday
to better understand how an attack could
unfold i think you have to look at every
possibility which is what we what we do
intelligence has been laid bare for
weeks announcing russian moves before
they're played a move experts call novel
but risky if you keep saying russians
are going to invade the russians are
going to invade and they don't then of
course it it dilutes your own
credibility as far as intelligence
reveals are concerned russia has
repeatedly said it has no intentions of
invading ukraine calling predicted dates
a provocation but with u.s reports now
suggesting that the kremlin may be ready
to move in western anxiety is palpable
jeff reggie takini in washington thanks
well wishes are pouring in tonight for
queen elizabeth after buckingham palace
confirmed she's tested positive for
covid19 the 95 year old monarch is said
to be experiencing mild symptoms and
she's set to continue light duties this
week as redmond shannon explains it
comes after a difficult week for the
royal family
it was a sign of how british life is
almost back to normal last wednesday the
queen met with representatives of the
british armed forces in person at
windsor castle good morning
how are you
well as you can see i can't move their
maskless meeting including old school
handshakes offered by the visibly frail
monarch so sunday's news of the queen's
positive covet test has reminded those
outside the castle walls that the
pandemic can still be a cause for
concern i'm just really upset obviously
i think everyone is upset because i
think everyone loves her as long as
she's okay that's all that matters
really isn't it we want her to recover
very quickly and we want to see her back
to herself again buckingham palace says
the queen has mild cold-like symptoms
and is carrying out light duties as she
isolates it's not known when she
contracted the virus on february 10
prince charles tested positive for covid
for the second time he had met with his
mother just two days before his positive
test the queen has had three doses of a
coveted vaccine and carried out most of
her engagements online during the
pandemic she had been scaling back her
duties in recent months after a short
hospital stay in october and after
spraining her back in november often
even people who develop
severe symptoms eventually start off
mild so i think anybody of that any
person of that age will need to be
monitored fairly carefully her diagnosis
comes just days after prince andrew
settled his civil lawsuit out of court
with virginia du frey the woman who says
he sexually assaulted her when she was
17
and after london police launched an
investigation into prince charles's
charitable foundation over allegations
it offered a saudi citizen royal honors
and british citizenship
this past week has certainly made for a
tough start to the queen's platinum
jubilee year she will turn 96 in april
jeff
redmond shannon in london thanks
coming up deep divisions how does canada
move forward in the wake of the convoy
crackdown
[Music]
go to me racing
[Applause]
more than 100 people rallied in toronto
in support of residents in ottawa the
crowd outside city hall included various
labor groups and they condemned what
they called the convoys display of hate
and its targeting and harassment of
communities in the nation's capital
in the wake of ottawa's convoy crackdown
alberta's premier is launching a court
challenge against the federal
government's emergencies act
the federal government's invocation of
the emergencies act is an unnecessary
and disproportionate measure that can
violate civil liberties invades
provincial jurisdiction and creates a
very dangerous but precedent for the
future and it's not necessary
weeks of protests and counter protests
have exposed deep divisions in this
country particularly over pandemic
public health measures in alberta where
the couts border crossing was blocked by
demonstrators the edmonton police chief
issued a plea to the public chris chacon
explains
a divided community
can be a dangerous community edmonton
police chief dale mcphee has been
calling for calm he has described the
political divisions highlighted by covet
19 policy as a fire i'm asking and
imploring political leaders
community members
everyone across the spectrum to help us
put this fire out but the fires continue
to rage on parliament hill divisions are
clear in edmonton on wednesday a staff
member at a liberal mp's edmonton office
was attacked the person who did show up
was a self-declared unvaccinated person
who was there to protest
and
and then the assault took place rhetoric
from leaders has been just as heated
this response comes from a question from
a jewish mp conservative party members
can stand with people who wave swastikas
they can stand with people who wave the
confederate
the house speaker admonished the prime
minister for that remark later former
mayors criticized premier jason kenney
for fanning the flames of divisiveness
after a tweet on pipeline protests and
david suzuki university of alberta
sociologist amy kaler says it has been a
long time since we've experienced this
kind of a divide the first thing that
comes to mind maybe because it's almost
exactly 100 years ago is if you look at
the descent and divergent opinions and
views around
the first world war conscription the
good news here kaler says this time the
divisions might not be as deep we hear
from those most upset but kaler says
most people aren't like that the bad
news all that noise could make it harder
to find common ground
seeing these things almost gives a sort
of permission effect for them to
continue because yeah it's real i saw
somebody can do it we've done it so you
know let's keep doing it and it'll take
a while i think for that to
die down meaning says kaler some views
need to change and like chief mcphee
says so too does the rhetoric chris
chicon global news
still ahead survival at sea rescuers
find a man alive after days drifting
aboard a burning ferry
you're watching global national
we'll take a look at this startling site
in chile thousands of dead sardines and
anchovies washed up on a beach
environmental officials are now
investigating the cause but locals say
that low oxygen levels in deeper waters
sometimes force the fish to swim closer
to the shore in search of nutrients
a plane chartered by the spanish
government landed in newfoundland today
to repatriate the survivors and some of
the victims of a shipwreck last week the
aircraft touched down in saint john's
and is expected to return three sailors
to spain tomorrow along with five of the
ten victims the remaining bodies will be
repatriated to peru eleven crew members
of that commercial fishing boat are
still missing
and a survivor has been pulled from a
burning ferry off the coast of greece
the bella russian man was reported
missing and presumed dead after the boat
caught fire three days ago he was found
in the stern of the italian-owned euro
ferry olympia the body of another
passenger was also recovered 10 people
are still unaccounted for an
investigation into the cause of that
fire is now underway
game's over coming up the closing
ceremony and reflections from the
olympics in beijing
[Music]
it was a winter olympics plagued by
covet 19 fears political controversies
and yet another russian doping scandal
the beijing games themselves though led
to some great results for canadian
athletes ross lord reports
shedding a cloud of controversy the
winter games ended in elegance true
television ratings for the beijing
olympics were at rock bottom levels but
many things that could have gone wrong
didn't it was wonderful sport it was
joyous sport
uh
the feared covet outbreaks did not occur
so the organizers managed that very well
also managing very well team canada a
medal count of 26 though heavy on bronze
and light on gold that total compares
favorably with canada's count at
previous winter games and this country
has new stars like ottawa speed skater
isabel weidemann named the flag bearer
at the closing ceremonies after winning
a bronze a silver and a gold medal
another canadian athlete hockey player
marie philippe poulet continued a run of
olympic excellence team captain pulan
scored the golden goal in the final game
for the third time propelling the
canadian women to an inspiring victory
over their american arch rivals
delivering a relatively smooth olympics
allows chinese officials to boast now
that beijing is the only city to host
both the summer and winter games
some say it's a public relations ruse
for a communist regime notorious for
alleged human rights abuses it does
cover over some major
major issues that do need to be dealt
with um and i think moving forward
canada needs to step up and and and
think about those human rights issues
the next winter olympics in 2026 will be
held in the italian cities of milan and
cortina dom pezzo sports fans will be
hoping for less political strife
and that the pandemic will feel like a
distant memory
ross lord global news that is global
national for this sunday night i'm jeff
semple tonight your canada is a real
hoot it's this snowy owl near meford
we would love to see your corner of the
country so please keep sending your
photos to viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching calling christy will
be at the anchor desk with you tomorrow
have a great night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you